good
morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast post our Halloween
extravaganza I don't know if I will ever
be able to say the word extravaganza
like ever since lady gaga had an
extravaganza on watch her up inside it's
all I could say yeah it's hard it slips
it slips out it's crazy they just come
back to the show as regular people on
November 1st and it's nice that October
31st is followed by November first
because now we're excited for the
holidays like it's my birthday month and
I know everyone's just like oh my god
what am I gonna get Jackie your
birthday's in like 16 literally the
hardest person to shop for has
everything because she loves to shop and
it has like the most a cream-of-the-crop
style where like I can't relate because
everything I get is from Target I think
that I am the easiest person to shop for
because you go into a store you see
something like pink and girly you're
like she'd love that
yeah but odds are you already have it no
but I go probably just run it by me
actually but if I don't but wait I
totally agree with what you're saying
like there's no slump after Halloween
where they're like after New Year's it
is depressing like it's just like
there's nothing then there's like
Valentine's Day that's not even like a
real holiday like you don't have time
off for that like you don't have time
off until Memorial Day like yeah it's
the [ __ ] worse but after Halloween
it's like you'd think you'd be sad like
there's no more candy but it's like wait
the candy goes on discount sale even
though I went to I just right actually
just reminded myself something else I
went to Duane Reade yesterday to get
toilet paper cuz we ran out and all
literally all of the entire candy aisle
was gone but it's not gonna go on sale
today well I'm glad people are eating
well well then that's the other thing
there was the cutest kid in this entrain
read with his mom he was all dressed up
ready for trick-or-treating and he was
like where do i trick or treat him like
honestly I don't know lately because I
inadvertently trick-or-treated all day
yesterday if you took my purse
filled with candy everywhere I went
there was a bowl of candy waiting for me
no but like for a kid no for a kid and
so also I was walking down the street
and there were doorman with bowls of
candy which I guess you go you could go
from building to building do but in your
own building you can go from Florida for
people sign up there were two apartments
on my floor that had a cauldron outside
of their door my Lobby had a cauldron I
got a manicure the manicure had a
cauldron people were trick-or-treating
in the nail spa I just felt like
everywhere was trick-or-treating I had
literally the opposite I didn't see one
piece of candy yesterday except for
those skittles
that you gave me and by the way I have
to tell you
I ate one of the skittles on my way home
it was the purple flavor and it was like
it was grapes grape soda flavored but
they really should have labeled it like
duty flavored I actually spit it out and
throw it out I must've been something
wrong with it it tasted like actual duty
but I felt so bad for this kid he just
couldn't find candy is well you know
it's it's his own fault no it's not here
there was sugar treating everywhere
yesterday we're trying so hard and I
literally picked up two or three mini
things everywhere I went I had a whole
bag full candy I put it in my drawer
because I'm on a diet for the CMAs right
now but at the day after the CMAs I'm
getting into that drawer I got the best
of the best mom enjoy Twix
mommy joy hit Kat what like if you are
in a bowl and there's like all the
regular stuff what are you gonna go for
kay well because I'm in joy it's an
underrated candy so people don't get it
so when I see and I enjoy I always grab
it but there's no sir but of the usual
suspects Twix are by far my favorite and
Kit Kat I will always take the Milky Way
and then the Kit Kat Milky Way is the
worst candy there's absolutely no need
for it it doesn't bring anything to the
party that any of the other candy store
ready
it's the Snickers without the chunky
peanut swear it's like first of all not
everyone can have peanuts
second of all sometimes you just want
like a light caramel delicious bite not
like a crunchy ass peanut butter so
sometimes I find this Snickers to be
like way too overwhelming to me the
Milky Way is a perfect formula of like
all the good things of a Snickers but
without the bad things you know um no I
disagree it's like it's missing
something because everything else has
something going on for it and I agree
sometimes Snickers is a little too much
um but that Twix that little shortbread
that's my least favorite part of the
Twix the shortbread
I just love caramel like one of my
favorite candies is the Godiva squares
that's milk chocolate with caramel
inside you know yes that's a good thing
so to me it's like the Milky Way is like
the drugstore version of that also
Reese's are delicious yeah very rich but
very good but also you can't get the
little crown you know the little ones
you need the big orange you have quarter
because the little ones have you put
them in your pocket macro tip they will
melt and you'll have a pocket full of
chocolate weight all just like Caleb on
our CMA Award stream last year speaking
of unnecessary candies I think you're
mistaking Milky Way for a 3 Musketeers
3 Musketeers is [ __ ] delicious it's
so whipped and like Oh weird it's like
diet candy it's not
it's lighter than the others I guess
it's a lighter the others are denser we
had a huge announcement on our toast
news network Instagram make sure you're
following that because we announced
we've been teasing for about a week our
new tienen show and people were truly
shocked because I think they were really
impressed with our level of you know
celebrity because we have secured Rayven
Gottschalk and Adams no raven adams
raven gates oh my god adam gosh it looks
like you know when people start to date
they really like become one good thing I
kept takin I kept typing her Instagram
today because I was posting on the toast
news network Instagram and I was typing
raven Gottschalk yeah that's good though
raven gates an adam Gottschalk they have
a new podcast called date night with
Raven and Adam it's gonna be a campaka
static ated to dating relationship
advice they're also getting married kind
of soon so I feel like we'll be getting
a real inside look on their wedding
planning process which is so excited we
just press you can't pay for so head
over it's on iTunes and Spotify right
now head over subscribe just type in
date night with Raven and Adam we are
very excited to have them on board to
make a port they're gonna be such great
podcasters first of all like Raven is
one of my favorite all-time bachelor can
has mid today love listening to her
voice like it is just so pleasing it's
none of this it's so darling and then
Adam also such a winner and he's so
smart so I feel like the two of them
together plus I love their relationship
and they're so like real and they went
there like such a TV couple and a real
life couple yeah you know but they are
very much like a real life couple I feel
like in the last year or two they've
truly like settled down started life
another getting married in the shul like
I love them and I'm excited to follow
their journey and I'm so glad that we
get to be a little bit a part of it at
TNN so I wrote out a few things I wanted
to talk about with you today because um
I had two experiences yesterday that I
wanted to discuss one about so you
wanted one dozen but Before we jump in
allow me
I watched Jimmy Fallon last night okay
and I don't really watch late-night
because it's on like kind of late and I
just would rather watch like friends or
something I enjoy but I was like let's
see what the the late-night landscape is
is up to these days and I watched Jimmy
Fallon and you know it's really
interesting if you watch Jimmy Fallon
under the guise of assuming that he's
wasted it's a totally different show an
Anatomy thinks he actually might be
drunk all the time because he's so crazy
and
I don't know if any normal human being
whether or not they work in the
entertainment industry would be that
crazy
he was just like bopping around the
stage like so nuts and then he had
Kristen Stewart and the kid from
stranger things with the teeth and
before they have their any views they
both played out and played a game of
Pictionary and it was Jimmy and Kristen
Stewart verse the stranger kids thing
and one of the guys from the roots and
it was truly like one of the most
awkward 10 minutes ever like I cannot
believe it like this is a million dollar
show it's like you have all the
resources in the world like this is the
crap you're putting together also the
stand-up that Jimmy does in the
beginning like some of the worst jokes
I've ever heard in my life like I can't
even repeat them because they were so
dumb like just and the thank you notes
memory that segment used to me like
everything they used to play it on taxi
TV his segment was like thank you
Walgreens like he would like make weird
jokes like through the guy like yeah
awful awful like I cannot believe how
far we've fallen on late-night TV like
Jimmy Fallon to me he shoots in New York
it's like the it should be the pinnacle
of like all things you know celebrity
and comedy and it was just like it was
awful damn I mean that's how surprising
and then I went over to Jimmy Kimmel and
he's interviewing someone the dad from
Spy Kids and he's dressed like a carrot
it was so stupid like I just couldn't
believe that like that is where TV like
no wonder nobody has cable anymore that
nobody needs to see that but like these
people are making literally millions of
dollars a year to do nothing it was so
stupid it's like you have a team of the
best comedy writers in the world and
you're writing a joke about how the
Washington Nationals logo looks like the
Walgreens logo like it was so stupid
that's really crazy I just I was shocked
Washington Nationals won the World
Series something that I meant to bring
up yesterday me too because I saw it
when I was looking for stories but if I
didn't see it I would have never known
that the World Series ended well I live
with Beckett so the Kate Upton's didn't
win and I didn't push like and I guess I
follow no Washington Nationals wives on
Instagram yeah so I wouldn't know but
that reminds me when I was watching it
two nights ago I wanted to mention it on
the toast yesterday but I forgot I only
caught like the last five minutes
because Ben was watching in the living
room but it was time for bed he said we
watch the last couple minutes and I said
of course and when they won all the guys
like ran onto the field and we're like
jumping and it was literally just like
it was hot like it was all these guys
you know big guys
running jumping hugging spraying like
licking each other it was just like so
it shifts off certain in the arena I was
like loving it yes when they want when
they want it say I'll storm the field
and I was like this is content I can get
me home that looks really fun and I feel
like that's you know the prize of
winning because otherwise you feel like
go back to the bench and the dugout with
like your tail between your legs
but like the party on the field is this
far is the winning and everyone's taking
pictures of you so it's like you're like
being like cute and glamorous yeah yeah
and then like everyone's taking selfies
yeah really cute I'm happy for the
Washington Nationals and then the other
thing I wants to tell you about I'm not
sure if you know this because you know
Twitter but we have been pulled into
some drama whoo so I guess like maybe a
month ago we spoke about BTS okay I've
been seeing some comments on our YouTube
that have shown me that we've been
pulled into some drama so I guess one
BTS fan account like clipped what we
said about it okay their variety article
said they've conquered kpop they've
conquered the American music now they
want a Grammy we were just like making
fun of them for like going on hiatus
when they went on a hiatus for literally
a month and then came back they could
have just not said anything and like no
one would have known it's like One
Direction is on a hiatus for three years
well you just what did we I just need to
know what I said we said we were making
fun of the fact that a hiatus is not a
month okay and if they've conquered the
kpop world and the the American music
wouldn't they have already won a Grammy
oh I honestly I don't recall any of this
I mean it and maybe remember a little
hiatus talk but talking about BTS
winning a Grammy like I've never I don't
know her so I would very much like to
read some of the tweets we've got this
is from an account called lock down cake
goog I could by the way like I heard
that they're I think they're gonna be
like in our YouTube oh my god there's a
one comment and I was like what in the
world they may not have gotten a Grammy
but that does not diminish any of their
other accomplishments whatsoever they're
[ __ ] you and ambassadors their name
and impact is more than a [ __ ] gold
record player on a bat black slab of
metal so [ __ ] you girl with no job
mourning toes I just want to say one
thing in these BTS first offense and by
the way I have the utmost respect for
BTS like we went to the Billboard Music
Awards they saw their fans like we saw
it is real and I think that all of that
means so much more than winning a Grammy
the fact that like when you even when
you're watching on TV you can hear BTS
fans more than you can hear anyone elses
yeah it's like that is means more and is
worth more than
winning a Grammy so I don't think that
BTS needs to prove anything to anyone by
winning a Grammy and please share it
with the rest of our hey you should I
had I had seen some comments that were
ignoring and I don't um
of course you irrelevant uglies however
that's what I come with BTS irrelevant
for a non speaking Korean group to
become so successful in the West and
conquering the area that's true by the
way diminishing that I couldn't agree
more
like we're all in agreement but all
we're saying is that they by the way
it's just pure logic if I had conquered
the pop world they would have won a
Grammy now it's all coming back to that
logic and to I'm sorry a one-month break
is not a hiatus I'm sorry I take I stand
by everything I said I'm not diminishing
their accomplishments I think that
they're called their stamp the hood is
crazy and it's impressive and I'm not
denying any of that but like less we not
you know forget one month does not a
hiatus make yet no I'm now understanding
what I was saying and I agree with her I
agree with her so I just want to say the
sixteen year olds who are telling us to
go [ __ ] ourselves like relax go do your
homework and talk to me later yeah and
it seems like we're on the same side
like BTS deserves a Grammy that's where
I'm at I'm not there I'm what I'm saying
was that if they had conquered both the
kpop and the pop world they would have
won a Grammy I don't know I'm kind of
with the BTS errs on this and now I see
both sides I understand why before I
said they obviously didn't conquer
American music because they didn't win a
Grammy but I think the Grammys are
becoming more and more irrelevant and
meaningless and that's true and I think
that them not winning a Grammy like
doesn't actually say anything and they I
like that the BTS stands like don't put
that much of emphasis on Grammys I'm
with you guys
I like the award shows are out of
control I really like them referring to
us as uglies yeah I think we should make
much irrelevant ugly that's actually
like oh really I always say like if
you're gonna come for me you've got to
be creative and I actually respect the
hell out of someone calling me in a rack
relevant ugly that is so funny oh my god
like I was just talking about this with
Benton cuz you know been like he just
hit started doing what he and not
something someone left a mean comment
I'm like Ben that's not even creative
like calling us fat like it's just
straight facts you know like we are like
it's not a big deal it's a medical term
at this point and I always say I'm like
if someone's gonna like say something
mean about me like I appreciate the
creativity like that's not even creative
calling me fat that's just like you look
that's like the most obvious thing about
me and right but they obviously like
watched our show they know a little bit
about us to call us irrelevant ugly
right and then and they looked at us
they thought we were ugly like I love
that ticket I I'm not upset like I
really love that and you know if we can
just ride this like BTS way we are on
our way says like I would I'll take
those those numbers give me to you
because you know for every like five BTS
haters there's like one or two is like
wait the shows kind of funny right I
know or even if they just all watch the
video where we talk [ __ ] and then they
continue talking [ __ ] like that video
will have like millions of views also
like people talk about BTS all the time
they're like arguably one of the biggest
bands in the world and like we're
talking about them and it's like the BTS
there's like find us relevant enough to
like speak on it and take a sound you
know I love that no I'm so hear more
nerd but it's also we're in a funny
place because there are comments that
are saying what's BTS so like we're just
we're caught between a rock and a hard
place
BTS is not our critically acclaimed
patreon series behind the scenes it's
not it is a kpop band that rose to fame
over the last one or two years they are
huge you probably have seen them at a
bunch of award shows in America over the
last few years people are just screaming
their heads off it's like seven guys
actually it looks like thirty guys
there's so many guys in that bad but you
should check out BTS I never heard one
their songs and I did a collab with
Halsey I understand why you would think
it was our patron series because like
there has been uproar that that series
does deserve a Grammy
Peabody Award winner yet for Best like
music video and like steam vibes yeah
and maybe maybe next year I don't know
but in the meantime check out
patreon.com slash the morning toast 5
October episodes are up they're really
great premium content podcasts if you
ever just like need if you have a long
car ride you need more content from the
scenes and they're way more personal
than these episodes we didn't talk about
bands like BTS like they're we talk
about ourselves yeah and also it just
feels like more comfortable to like talk
about yourself when it's behind a
paywall
right for sure I totally agree like I'm
not just gonna give it all up look
spread my legs for free for YouTube why
buy the cow if you get in the milk for
free so true anyways now I'm glad that
you got that all up your test because I
do think that it's time to deliver you
yeah I do I was just like why not oh by
the way the snitches in here oh yeah she
has strep throat again cuz I wasn't sure
if it was time usually a snitch when I'm
not sure right um but she's not there so
I don't know if it's time for wishing
her well she has strep throat again
she's on antibiotics and steroids and
she's feeling much better which is good
because she has to accompany me to
Toronto tomorrow for my sold-out
I am [ __ ] excited there certain shows
like I just know we're gonna be late and
it shows that sellout like Toronto must
be I think it actually is one of our
toasty US cities the show sold out like
instantly and it was like a 2,000 person
theater like I can't believe and I'm
very excited if you weren't able to get
ticket to em coming back to Canada to
Rama Ontario it's like two hours out of
Toronto so I I'm hopeful that you guys
will come it's a casino too so you know
I'm gonna be partying the night away
afterwards I also added a bunch of shows
tickets are available girls no job
comment got Kansas City Missouri
Atlantic City New Jersey Englewood New
Jersey Verona New Yorker own what a
minute Terry
Tarrytown New York I hope you guys can
make it head over to girls no job home
for tickets now mm-hmm
apparently this Mitch is watching live
comes to switch we love you we miss you
and we're so excited for this not sure
to come back this is just a really big
week for tienen oh my god okay I'm so
excited Margot hi how are you hi how are
you oh my god I was like watching every
star videos all night he was being so
funny the collab drops today the palette
at 10 a.m. Pacific time so 1 a.m. and 1
p.m. here newer I still haven't decided
it from getting anything okay well you
actually made me want to get a mirror
just like not even maybe a collab one
just like a jeffree star one because you
were saying I was saying how I don't
think I need it and then today I'm
shooting my makeup like with the with it
in my mind like when when I use a mirror
and for my eyebrows and eyelashes that
would definitely use it probably
eyeshadow too I've been loving it I
wanted to get the lip balm that's in a
lipstick case but then I saw it on
Twitter it's some root beer-flavored and
I don't know if I would like that I
think you might you like dying is the
pressure of like you have to be on at
one o'clock you know II mean I know we
have a 12:30 meeting and then a 1:30
meeting so like I don't know where maybe
at 1 o'clock no but you could set an
alarm and I'm sure it could maybe snag
something I just don't I haven't like
figured it out least all the products
like you should look at it before like
looks at everything I don't want any of
the lipsticks those are not my color I
do think I want the clear gloss I love a
clean yeah which is such a good day I'm
such a good name I think maybe I'll do
the mini controversy palette but I just
I know I don't need it I know so I would
just be getting it to like be part of
the culture I guess that's my job to be
part of the culture that's true and you
know what I do think it is a business
expense
yeah it's research you um we could do a
patreon video of us doing our makeup oh
that's a good idea and like actually try
some new styles
I was also thinking you know I'll talk
about we need to have a business meeting
okay we're having a business meeting
very exciting very excite
anyways snitch love you miss you yeah
well soon we love our fans sending that
to the fan you're the fans like they
really are just love you yeah okay
um without further ado it is time for
the Fast Five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast alright is
that okay with you I think it is great I
have nothing to say today Wow
love it nothing on your chest nothing
weighing you down no okay well there's
plenty things weighing me down
physically you know my breasts are large
you know my food was hanging and in
charge
yeah but right now I'm good okay we're
gonna get right into it our first story
is Kardashian weaned it's just over
arching latest story yeah um to me just
I don't even know where to begin with
these girls who have served us in the
past 24 hours collectively about 10
different Halloween looks and I want to
serve from the top with the best costume
of the year well actually let's I feel I
have a better way to organize our
thoughts
let's start by each daughter starting
just with the oldest Cortney yeah Casali
Parton really not inspired by her
costume she Reshard video of her and KC
Matsuri dancing and spelled Kacey
Musgraves name wrong
yes spec now the Kardashians have
disrespected Kacey Musgraves not once
but twice yeah but at least like she was
invited to the party she dressed as DCC
she looked so cute she looked incredible
and it's I just I [ __ ] love her I'm
so happy for her and like all of this
the success she's having like obviously
career-wise but also in the social
environment of Hollywood yeah but then
it's like you also know that she's still
just a dime-store cowgirl
right you know that none of this is
getting to her and like that's why we
stand no so [ __ ] hard we stand so
[ __ ] hard more than ever
yeah Courtney hello goodbye Kim Kim
Kardashian dressed as L was she won she
was she really won Halloween complete
library um the level of dedication and
the real transformation that she went
through she really looks so different
not only that the level of videography
like they must have used to set yes so
that's what I want to talk about is is
that specific incident and also like
what Halloween even means in 2019 right
but first let's talk about the photos
and videos she now that she recreated
Elwood
is Harvard admissions video and to beti
every line perfect every outfit perfect
every set perfect song perfect and it
was literally like watching the ariana
grande thank you next music video
why yes Marco I do it was so [ __ ]
good I live just love when celebrities
acknowledge like other cultural
references because you think they just
live in their own world like they've
never even seen Legally Blonde yeah and
she also acknowledges that like everyone
is calling her the Elwood's of our
generation
and now she's in law school like there
were so many just connections that made
it so pertinent and I never would have
guessed this cuz you know Kim is like
kind of shy and they would have never
thought she would have put together a
video like us watching the video I was
like oh my god we were just like
watching her come out of her shell it's
like I feel like this is so not Kim and
she was really reminding me of Chris in
the video the way she was talking she
was talking like Kris Jenner and I just
like I loved it from her but now it's
like in Halle in 2019 Halloween means
getting all dressed up taking pictures
and recreating um moment iconic moments
like on video for Instagram and that's
it and that's the costume and the
Kardashians are doing it more than
anyone and they actually are going out
which is cool but it's like Halloween
now is just like creating content
honestly I'm here for it because
Halloween dressing up is super fun but I
found Halloween parties to be torturous
like you're so uncomfortable in your
costume art of dressing up for Halloween
was about like getting into costume but
also like what can you go out and like
what can you live with and shoes you can
actually walk in and like you know a wig
that will stay on your head but now it's
just like you pose for one picture
can I just Photoshop myself into every
Halloween costume I want right like when
did Kim do that video I feel like that
was like weeks ago and she never even
was legally blond like maybe we do a
Halloween shoot in May right and a video
and I'm not against it necessarily I
just think it's really interesting I
think it's a sign of the time yeah what
did heidi klum end up being I was filing
wound up do you not see it I did I
didn't know what it was oh I didn't know
what it was either but it's poop she's
an Amazon partnership where she sat in
front of the Amazon there's an Amazon
store front and I think Union Square he
didn't swear yeah it's a huge Amazon
store and they closed it and she did her
all of her glam prosthetics hair and
makeup from like 9:00 in the morning
yesterday and she did it right in the
window of the Amazon stores like people
were walking by people were standing
outside watching and I was soaking
uses what she was I still don't know I
don't know either I thought she was
gonna be the night king the whole thing
that's what I thought
well I said that that's where I was in
my brain um the whole thing was strange
like the sitting in that was on window
very Thursday like the whole parties
become like a big thirst trap which I
guess that money I was invited I just
want to put it out there but I've
decided not to go I went the last two
years it's just it's super fun but it's
just like it's a lot of work to me that
Thursday and I just didn't have it in me
I felt like a cold coming on you know
it's why I'm wearing a turtleneck yeah I
feel like it's just turned into like a
media press event and not like a
celebrity star-studded affair which is I
think what it started out as right and
now she's found a way to monetize it and
I'm happy for her and I totally got that
but and in this costume usually she does
like something crazy amazing like when
she was just a rabbit I was arriving
was she Fiona from Shrek once mmm she
was a cloned and cloned she was also
like a true old woman she had like crazy
prosthetic she's always been something
that you can like assign a name to yeah
and I don't know maybe it's from a movie
you know what I'm just gonna give it
like one chance I'm gonna click on the
article to see if there's a name for the
costume she just looks like a robot you
know II online says Heidi Klum's bloody
Halloween costume is her scariest yet
you're trying to get me to sign up for
your newsletter II it is just not gonna
happen but again do we know what it is
no no they can't they won't let me see
it I need to sign up for their
newsletter let's find out okay for the
milestone 20th year of her signature
Halloween party [ __ ]
after she the star topped herself once
again as an alien that's let's just say
you don't want to get close to okay no
sir that's it she was a nondescript
alien or maybe she was like an that is a
[ __ ] crazy costume I know Wow
okay I wasn't expecting that anyways
yeah I don't get it
no me that's a night that's mine you
could be anything in the world and then
Kim also dressed up with her family as
the Flintstones
okay she posted the pictures this
morning they are the most precious gems
of photos I've ever seen in my wedding
she was Betty she had North be Wilma
Chicago was BAM pebbles oh yeah and st.
was bamm-bamm no I'm sorry st. was Fred
Flintstone right she was really
confusing with the ages yeah and like
hos
like technically she was married to
saying or something right you know
whatever I don't mind where was Kanye
there
he hasn't been posted in any photos yet
but she's also just posting the photos
now like maybe she even posted somebody
they are just so [ __ ] precious oh my
god that's a cute ass [ __ ] costume
I'm down for trick-or-treating ya know
it's obvious that they all did many a
costume change I think they probably
also wore that to Kylie's daytime party
so can I get a kids party so cute Chloe
dress up as Cruella De Vil
she looks great for you as a Dalmatian
and I just I loved it I'm really the
question we posed yesterday is like who
is becoming the faces of Halloween and
for me it's the Kardashians men were
they were the Angels last year that was
so iconic
they're always just her and like Kim
with Selena she was sharing such a chair
like they to me do it right they use all
of their resources to just [ __ ] nail
it and they love it me too and then I
guess Kendall threw like a Halloween
party parties like for adults it's so
funny yeah cuz like I guess the party of
the year was last night at Kendall's
like everyone was there but it's so
funny because it would have appeared
that Kylie had like a competing party
but if you look at the time stamps Kylie
had a daytime party like for kids with
like a bouncing house and then Kendall
had like a range here with 1942 and it's
just so funny how like they're in such
different places in there but I think
that Kylie went to that so it's like
they it wasn't like they're doing
different things you can really have it
all you can know they really have it on
they like took the kids
trick-or-treating stormy we haven't
talked about that video stormy playing
basketball yeah so [ __ ] cute guys
it's the [ __ ] cutest video I've ever
seen every time I watch it it's just
more and more precious they're just
crushing it with their preciousness no
kylie is crushing it with the content
like in the past month no and in the
past week like I think she's just on
like a Halloween bender in the best
possible way like no judgments
whatsoever because she's like being a
mom but she's also being a 22 year old
party animal good and I think she's been
like drunk every night I don't know how
she's hungover because she's trying to
yeah definitely not definitely not
um and I'm just I'm living for this
chapter of their lives meet you it's so
fun it's like cool to watch it's very
aspirational like that is what I want to
be as a mom like I just want to be fun
and like still go out but like also be
like such a good mom and like throw my
kids you know parties with bouncy
castles yeah and I just I think for next
year like actually it's funny because I
felt like I wasn't participating in
Halloween but we dress up on Halloween I
think that's also a part of getting
older is like Oh Halloween is only
celebrated on October 31st and I'm so
okay with that and now it's like
everyone loved our Halloween costume I
was so Halloween and I was very happy
the content
was so I know we're not like that's what
you're saying at all is about the
content now but it's like Joe Jonas
reposted us Gweneth commented crying
emoji on us as the Jonas Brothers hiding
Jonas liked our morning toast video yeah
Jonas file somewhere and chose and then
so did the Jonas Brothers manager right
so it was just like it was we hit it out
of the park so I did participate even
though I was feeling like it was really
this FOMO that Instagram had instilled
in me because I see that everyone is at
Halloween parties starting on October
20th and I'm like I'm not celebrating
Halloween and those party looked so
[ __ ] fun Halley Bieber was there
looking so goddamn cute I didn't really
get what she was this is all a bunny
from Space Jam she looks great and then
Kacey Musgraves was there a bunch of
other people but the coolest part was
that all like the waitstaff the waitress
is serving drinks were wearing replicas
of Kendall's Met Gala outfit to that big
orange Versace feather item which I just
I love a creative you know event
planning technique yes you I I'm getting
word that Kanye was the purple Dino yes
he was oh my god she did just post a new
photo Jake if you could get that picture
and put it in a Kim slay the sensor oh
my that is so the whole family
participated in it this family pic was
such a challenge because Chicago was so
scared of Dino lol we tried to explain
and show her that it was just daddy but
she didn't get the concept yet so shout
out to the photographer for editing her
in and making our family Flintstones
dream come true so [ __ ] you guys this is
the cutest thing I've ever seen in my
whole life and I actually I might love
this even more than that woods so like
do we think I'm from yesterday during
the day um I don't know I didn't see any
like real-time content but I also
haven't watched Kim's stories yet also I
do feel like they put so much effort
into these things like it it might have
been a few days and also they'd like a
backdrop that's like Flintstones II so
it looks like they have to like make
that in advance you know yeah Wow crazy
times that's amazing very cute it's
really it's really so cute
okay Halloween is for the kid it that's
what it is it's like now I feel like
we're in this weird period we're like
we're not we don't have kids yet more
like a little too old like still be
partying on Halloween so it's like we
have to wait until our kids arrive till
we can like get ourselves back into it
yeah and then you get to like for a few
years decide what they're going to be
yeah they're just like an accessory to
you yeah for sure
and I'm
little bum that Kylie didn't have
storming dress up as flounder when she
was a little mermaid did she like had a
purse that was flounder um I just feel
like stormy like if I were stormy host
yeah I mean I did speak to swarming
she's very upset yeah I understand she's
taking it out on basketball court
totally okay very healthy expression of
her anger that is just our celebrity
Halloween recap I loved it while it
lasted let's move on yeah aren't you
ready to move on from her intruder
unless Kim wants to wow us within we
love you we love you Kim and Kylie and
the whole Kardashian family even
Courtney next up some some legal news
that felt pertinent to the situation
Cuba Gooding jr. has been arraigned on
new sex abuse charges
shocker kidding me pretends to be
shocked Cuba Gooding jr. was arraigned
Thursday on new sex charges related to a
third alleged sex abuse victim as
Manhattan prosecutors revealed that more
women have come forward with claims
against the actor quote not guilty said
the Jerry Maguire star who was escorted
into the courtroom in cuffs Gooding
faces a total of six misdemeanor counts
of forcible touching and sex abuse
stemming from three accusers allegations
now this is where it gets interesting
because earlier this week a video was
leaked to TMZ which shows the after
tapping the backside of a tau nightclub
server on October 24th 2018 and by the
way it actually makes sense that when I
saw the video I didn't know that she was
an a club server and it actually makes
sense why she had such like a visceral
reaction to it cuz I'm sure that happens
to her a lot I mean I was singing like
wow this girl really knows how to dodge
shake a predator like it almost as if
she has experience yeah but she works at
Tao which is a nightclub and she
definitely does not experience that
sadly yes so now they're accusing the
defense team of like leaking this video
purposely to TMZ but we need all the
evidence I love a strategic defense I'm
not gonna lie no total I don't care this
is so long otter you know it's like you
can't get it as admissible evidence you
just leaked it to the local page six
reporter that is so something and Olivia
Benson would do yeah no good stuff yeah
except sometimes like the media [ __ ]
ruins cases when they get too involved
in like oh well never I will never
forget the assassination of Gianni
Versace and that radio station that said
that the car was on the road and so he
had to get a new car and he had to kill
a man in order to get a new car
and that man would still be alive today
the radio station didn't [ __ ] leak
information that they should not have
but I never saw that show but I think
about it all the time too because you
you explained it to me so well Oh
thank you it's a great example of like
where do we draw the line like he took
Lima Glen's car he was driving it so the
radio station reported he's driving
maybe the Lima Glenn's car so he had to
get rid of the car like so he had to
chose another one kill a random man who
works at a cemetery like I [ __ ] can't
and I shan't and they just never
reported that he would have they could
have caught him like they are giving
away the evidence yeah again for what
for what ratings like no one's listening
to her [ __ ] show
yeah police radios dead everyone's
watching Joe oh my god I just love
reporting on Cuba Gooding jr. news like
it really puts me in a good mood like I
just cannot wait for the day where
homeboy is sentenced you know a
necessary we're just I'm very much
looking forward to justice being served
yeah I heard I heard Claudia ah she was
looking forward to justice being served
Cheers that's your official statement
official statement sucka a little bit of
that too like you could suck my dick bro
um next story if I was gonna say
something crazy but I woke tonight next
story is for the best yet is a bit of
tienen news making news a story that I
would have chosen and it turns out it's
our own girl Lauren Elizabeth in the
headlines making headlines Joey King
explains why it was quote totally worth
it filming kissing booth - with her ex
Jacob oh lordy
which a lot of people are definitely
wondering about I'm sorry I need a sip
of your hobby okay I made it pretty good
too much ice in here yeah I had to like
really put effort into it be delicious
this snatchler wasn't around to make it
for me she makes the best coffee thank
you so much well 21-year old actress
Joey King appeared on Wednesday October
30th episode of the podcast mood with
Lauren Elizabeth CNN special they forgot
they left a part I did but you know we
always say here Us Weekly respects the
hell out of the morning toast and we
respect Us Weekly where she said it was
quote fine working with the Lord II
quote um it's a great movie she said I
personally am a fan of how it resonated
with the world and it resonated with me
so going back and doing that and making
the sacrifice obviously what everyone is
thinking about I'm not outwardly
addressing but when I'm kinda on the sly
addressing making those sacrifices was
totally worth it so I guess like being
around her ex which is so [ __ ]
awkward and having to kick him again it
may be in a booth was worth it because
the movies gonna be premium content and
like thank you but we came for your
sacrifice that's the object that I truly
needed and you know what when in the
beginning of the podcast episode she was
just talking about her she's been baking
a lot and
she like very suddenly mentioned her
boyfriend so she's dating someone else I
think she instagrammed with him actually
so you know what all's well that ends
well with Joey King and we're getting a
sequel and I'm excited about it and you
know what I love to pick up on on
nuances like in the movie like maybe
we'll notice you know some discrepancies
like you know some tension or maybe not
because she's an emmy-nominated actress
so truth you want to feel if you want to
know how she felt about losing the Emmy
tune in to mood with Lauren Elizabeth
yeah it's up now it's a good episode
yeah anyway just very interesting news I
love you know TNN making headlines yeah
and I'm really excited for kissing booth
too me too I feel like it's taking a
super long time I feel like it took a
long time for them to start filming and
now they're filming so would probably be
in the year right like to all the boys I
loved before I said what it's called
filmed super quickly and I think they
filmed two movies Wow Wow methinks makes
you think okay
kudos Antonio for a minute yeah you know
what I was just thinking about him
because he's in Charlie's Angels he is
yeah I was on the Charlie's Angels
official Instagram because as much as
the movie looks like garbage I am
interested in this piece of garbage and
he was in a clip and I started to watch
the clip but I was like why would I
watch a clip for a movie that like I'm
gonna see who is spoiler I think he's a
love interest of one of the waitress
that's crazy yeah he's he's a big movie
star like that I know well I wanted to
talk about his career because he came
off to other words I loved before like
America's Sweetheart and they could have
put him in enough Netflix movies and I
kind of feel like he didn't go where he
was supposed to go Jamie I mean he's
still on the journey I think now being
in movies like Charlie's Angels like
that'll get him to like this teen
heartthrob movie star and he is that guy
like whenever you think of like who's
the teen heartthrob movie they're like
it's nois Antonio um but I just think
like something about his little like
weird like I feel like he was America's
boyfriend and then America got to know
him no I took he was America's boyfriend
and then people went on his Instagram
and we're like wait are you my boyfriend
yeah like uh my boyfriend wouldn't do
that I think we got a breakup ya know
he's he's interesting yeah but I think
that's fine yeah I feel I expect I to
feel Peter Krause what's the same Peter
Karofsky yeah like just like a writ like
a boy next door he's nice he's like
artsy and write weird blogs to go out
his beard which is cool but it's like
when I hear that Noah San Antonio is in
a movie like I'm
I'm excited to see it yeah oh they got a
great leading man yeah so I think that's
how you should feel and I think his
career it shouldn't just be like he was
in a movie and now he's a big sensation
like it's just it's it takes times
growth so I think he's in a great place
and he's dating Alexis Wren and yeah I
don't know about that yet either I don't
know but they actually they seem happy
and cute and in love great which is all
you can ask from your celebrity couples
really so true and post premium pics
that's speaking of celebrity couples who
are posting non-premium pics to do see
Miley Cyrus and Cody Simpson being
absolutely dehydrated on its scream last
night dressed up as something I don't
even know they spent all day in
documenting their costume getting ready
on Instagram and I still don't know what
they are
um I saw because you like flip your
phone towards me so I saw they're making
out and she's a wig yeah she's making
out she's wigging out and the it's out
of control I'm sorry if the whole thing
is out of control officially that's my
verdict and I'm not really keeping up
with it anymore
Noemi there was too much to give up but
the first it was like wow they posted
together why they posted together again
now it's like stop posting together yeah
we'll give each other for a minute go to
work yeah it's it's too much too soon
yeah agreed okay next story is a bit of
strange news Amanda knocks to pen advice
column first NAT Seattle newspaper
specifically do you watch the Amanda
Knox tackle I mean nothing about Amanda
nah okay here's the thing i watch the
documentary and i still know nothing
about amanda knox and like if I had it
to like decide if she did it or not like
I really don't [ __ ] know yeah I mean
she's just out here being so thirsty
that like I kind of think she did it
based on no evidence nothing at all it's
just like I always think like okay if
this were me and I was like a private
citizen wasn't a public figure like the
huge star that I am now and I was
accused of murder and I really didn't do
it but I became like a huge sensation
from it like once I got off like I would
really hide like it's I don't know
there's something weird about it heard
like thirsting out after having such a
weird like a rise to fame you know what
I mean I don't know if I didn't do it
and I got off but I had Fame I'm taking
this thing all the way we started a
podcast I'm certainly nice column she
actually should have a podcast not an
advice well that's what I thought when I
read this but then I read the article
and
made a lot of sense because she does
have ties to this newspaper Knox will be
periodically answering readers submitted
questions in her new column titled ask
Amanda Knox all the questions she's
gonna get is did you do it which will be
published in the Seattle area news
outlet Westside Seattle if any Seattle
toasters are have a copy please
Alessa they sent us any interesting
answers the weekly print and online
newspaper serves parts of Seattle and a
few surrounding cities the Seattle
native NOx recently married Christopher
Robinson isn't that the guy from Winnie
the Pooh whose family publishes the
newspaper which is why she's giving them
the exclusive Wow she was already late I
just want to say something to all the
single toasters out there
Samantha knocks can get committed I can
get accused of murder and still find a
husband there is hope for you you will
find love a husband whose family
publishes a news right rich a Rupert
Murdoch max was already listed as a
contributing writer and photographer for
the publication who she'd reduced
opinion pieces about her time in Italy
her family and even her religion okay so
she need just like it's like actually
you know what that's exactly what I
would do after I found a husband I would
be like milk it how do you work you put
me to work
this is so weird I'm sorry like I can't
get on board with the thirsting I'm a
like of a accused murderer like I know
we're all innocent she's away today but
this is weird it's so weird it's odd
they watch the documentary for the facts
but I don't know what the facts are and
I watched and I like I don't know any of
the details like who was she accused of
murdering her roommate in Italy while
they were studying abroad oh for sure
for sure for sure but like what you just
go study abroad like anyone and you
murder know like people who study abroad
like that time away and like that kind
of sense of anonymity can [ __ ] get to
you I believe it like I I get it like I
know some people who [ __ ] changed
abroad okay that's all I'll say
it's a crazy [ __ ] time in your life
it's like freedom on set
oh it's nuts I never did it but the
sense of like freedom and liberation
with like you're not tethered to like
any school like you were just like
you're literally in a foreign land but
like all the resources that college
affords you and with like your own
apartment yeah I already have a roommate
and she's getting in your way that's
what I'm saying
I could totally understand how like that
sense of
like freedom and like responsibility can
get to a person and make them commit
murder commit murder like i 100% think
she did it you know when I've never even
I've heard her name because like
obviously I don't live under a rock but
I never bothered to like understand what
she was ever accused of or like where it
even knows in Italy but now just like
hearing the facts from you I'm 100%
certain that she did it case closed
where's my dad oh I'm sorry uh who I
want to give credit
Melissa Riviera I was crack the case Oh
Pluto it was the Italian camper she's
just fling to another country totally
totally um Sadie Sanchez is saying she
loves studying abroad and like I'm sure
you did like yeah all that independents
like in a new land you've stopped on a
plane you were in a new land
independently you sure loved it I don't
know I mean maybe that's just because we
never did it um I just first of all I'm
not like a big traveler so it's like
just on an interest level like I don't
wanna leave America I love like the big
portions here like everything Italy's
like so small like I don't know but you
can eat all that pasta and you don't
gain weight because of the ingredients
yeah but like I don't know they didn't
tell me that before I made my decision
culturally like I'm much more American
than I am Europe like I'm more tacky
like I just Europe stopped for me like
the small the small everything you know
the small beds the no air conditioning I
think I'm very much American so it never
really interested me to go abroad and I
got the the lure for other people but as
someone who was like in a relationship
like I just didn't find it necessary at
all but now I think I'm like now I'm in
the face of my life like what I let my
kids go abroad I'm like absolutely not
obviously I'm not letting my kids cross
the street you get like no way Jose and
also it's kind of like we were saying in
the patreon episode how it's like right
now at 27 years old like I feel ready to
go to high school and it was like I just
feel like at the time that abroad was
opposed like I'm Way too young to be in
a foreign country by myself like maybe
maybe now I can handle it you know I
would go down with you yeah but like
you're so young at 20 no but I think to
some of the crazy things I did as a kid
like how I didn't die is so shocking to
me and like I was doing so many things
like when I should have been like home
like I was crazy so now I know all the
secret it's like my kids you know
leaving the house yeah oh you want to go
to school I'll walk you yeah
you know I'll become a teacher yeah how
does certain lunch wait you have eaten
your tonsils out get over here you want
to see a movie I never see a Broadway
show I give my regards to Broadway
remember me from Herald Square totally
from like hear the sounds of marching
fee to 42nd Street don't tell me not to
live just sitting Potter life's candy
and the sons of balla balla don't bring
around a cloud to rain on my parade
someone made a really interesting point
Maria Gonzales again okay I think
studying abroad to some people is the
equivalent of camp to you guys would you
let your kid go to camp by the way it's
so different for smoke yeah I disagree
with that point hip is a controlled
environment with staff whose job it is
to look after your like you know how
we're all here an hour away you're not
the transformer abroad looking out for
you there's no Ras there's no like
there's nothing right ends only two
months versus six months but no but I
don't agree with that it's the
equivalent but 1,000% my kids are going
to camp you know many valuable lessons I
learned how to make my bed at camp like
everything I can't be have to clean up
after yourself you have to learn
sportsmanship you have to learn to get
along with others play on the team I I
think I am so amazing and part of that
is because I went to camp and like
learned how to be a [ __ ] team player
okay I agree but what if you had like on
the rottens had the same thing but I
wouldn't because all you learn how to do
abroad it's like get [ __ ] and do drugs
like that's what happens and attain
smoke oh for sure puke and like we're
Doc Martens and [ __ ] okay yeah class how
do you get those credits and how do you
get to class I don't know I went to go
visit here here's my equivalent
I never went abroad my dear friend
Rachel went to Florence and for my
Spring Break while I was still in
America we all went to go visit her
great time you know we traveled to
Florence took a couple days in Berlin
don't recommend it it's not a fun town
it's just
like just reminds me of the Holocaust
I'm sorry it's too sad and it was great
and I had a good time I couldn't imagine
needing any more not even one more
minute abroad like I saw it all you know
I saw the Duomo I climb the stairs you
know a quarter of the way and then I
went back down like I said I saw some
Melissa Riviera again with the point I'm
just interested in what people are
saying cuz man same experience I want to
hear from other I know we both agree on
this and she said my friends who studied
abroad are way more mature than me so I
kind of think I should have taken the
leap okay I want to say all my friends
studied abroad I'm the most mature by
the way I completely agree and I
actually beg to differ
I'd rather just say the people who
stayed back when it like not is it's not
the most popular thing to not go abroad
it's like you're not going abroad it's
like no Amira's well like it's not the
most popular thing and I think those
people are more mature for having to
deal with the societal peer pressure
yeah and no and for having to say like I
know this is what everyone does but it's
not for me to like know yourself well
enough to know that it's not for you so
mature yeah and like yeah everyone who
goes abroad like I'm sure it's cool for
like a month two months six months no
it's crazy what else are people saying I
want to refute and they're loving your
singing if you want to don't tell me not
to live just sin para life's candy and
the sons bar the butter
don't bring around to clear out to rain
on my parade don't tell me not to fly
I've simply got to if someone takes a
spill it's me and not you who told you
you're allowed to rain on my parade how
much my band out I'll beat my drum and
if I'm fanned out your turn at bat some
at least I didn't fake it mr. hat sir I
guess I didn't make it bad weather
around the rows of Shep effect shutting
a freckle on the nose of life's
complexion the cinder or the shiny Apple
of its eyes
I got a try once I got a flood once only
kintyre ones right sir
well life is juicy juicy and you'll see
you see yeah I gotta have my bite sir
get ready for me love Kazama comer
I've simply got a March my heart's a
drama who told you
you know allowed to rain on my parade
I'm gonna live and live now get what I
want I know how one role for the whole
shebang one throw that bad we'll go
Clegg I am the target and we're to one
shot one gunshot and bam sorry
hey mr. Arnstein
I'll watch my baby my drum Hanny fan fan
your turnout back sir
at least I didn't fake it's your hat sir
I guess it didn't make it get ready for
me love cuz I'm a come on I've simply
got a March my I have to trauma no buddy
no buddy
yes good night
thank you so much
well incredible work the work inspired
by Rachel Berry so kids how'd you like
the Broadway show so inspiring mom
you're the best let's never leave the
house okay I have some more perspectives
because no not about those people
agreeing with us
Hannah Lou bleh I didn't go to camp or
study abroad and I'm a [ __ ]
incredible
so put your I've met you yeah and
actually you did go to camp you went to
camp toast true um I do not go abroad
and everyone who comes back comes back
as a loser so true like wearing a scarf
and a beret being late
oh this pasta is not even comparable to
the pasta I had in Positano I have
friends who went to Chile and went as
Nick and came back saying his name was
Nico I'm [ __ ] disi oh my god that is
hilarious dude it's like ever just comes
back with like an ascot you know nobody
needs that no didn't get the real fast
five stories no no have one more and
it's um
it's some business and it's something
we've been talking about for a while
that is finally a decision has been made
because a judge has approved the sale of
Barney's to authentic brands Wow a
bankruptcy judge approved Barneys New
York Inc sale to authentic brands group
and owner and manager of fashion brands
which will likely close almost all of
the luxuries retails luxury retailers
remaining stores and licensed at
Barney's name so this is interesting
because the judge's decision lead to
open the slim possibility that a rival
purchaser could come forward before the
sale closes Friday morning Amanda um
yeah and we're like 40 minutes away from
it be in the afternoon right with a
higher or better offer that would keep
more stores open and businesses intact
don't look at it I want to read it to
you but someone said I have friends who
went to Chili's the restaurant and came
back and I believed it we went to
Applebee's once and I was a changed
woman by the way Applebee's I
I know Applebee's I eat there all the
time but like people in my family think
they're too good to eat at Applebee's
and I took you guys in Palm Springs Palm
Springs and change your life yeah no I
think it made me rethink everything I
thought I now know what it's like what's
really shocking and it's exactly where
the broad is supposed to do for you but
just go to Applebee's right and you know
what's talking about Applebee's that
doesn't come through in any of their
advertising like it is a clean
fresh restaurant like you think of
Applebee's you consider it like just
like another like chain fast-food
restaurant like no it is they have tons
of healthy options it's super clean I
don't work for Applebee's I'm just
letting you know like people think
they're too good for Applebee's and I
just want you to know you're not okay
you are not you are not you're no one is
too good for Applebee's no it's so clean
and good like I've been there so many
times and I'm just always surprised by
like the cleanliness and the level of AB
service I was surprised with the
creativity of the menu options like a
warm pretzel bike beer cheese yeah with
all the different kinds of dippings like
thank you know it's Janice I love
Applebee's except the Applebee's in the
cities is not it but the city I don't
blame Applebee's B's I blame the city of
New York yeah I don't play okay I just
want to close this Barney story because
I just want everyone to know what it
means for my gift card for your gift
where does it mean for my gift card
because um it means that there might
start like if they're closing the stores
everything will go on sale which is
actually really interesting thing
because it's before all the other stores
would do their holiday sales so
everyone's gonna like buy up what's at
Barney's and it's like I think it's
gonna [ __ ] with the market a little bit
it's great for the consumer um but I
think retail might struggle when here's
something terrible I just had dinner
with a bunch of my high school friends
my best friend Anna she was registered
she just got married she was registered
at Barney only [ __ ]
so what do you do oh I don't know you
guys been there every day
I gotta make change registry yeah how
crazy that's crazy also it's sad because
there will probably inevitably be
layoffs yeah but is that I but I hope
that whatever they build within the
space of the flagship Barney's and other
Barney's stories is something bigger
matter yes so they're saying they're not
gonna keep any of the stores the flow
but they're gonna keep the name line
yeah and they're gonna license that to
Saks and then they're gonna take all the
merchandise and sell it and I guess
they're oh they're licensing it to sighs
yeah to do what like make its own line I
don't know oh that's so interesting
mm-hmm business is interesting my friend
and then I would love to know what
they're gonna do with that store on 62nd
of madison arguably like the best block
in the city 62nd I'm accident man I live
there maybe God love yes I was loved to
squat on 62nd in Madison me too wow
that's like a rich squatter Street yeah
yeah totally
anything else me to discuss with where
we closed out for the weekend
no some reminders are Newton and
challenged Raven and Adam it's called
date night with Raven and Adam from The
Bachelor they're engaged they live in
Dallas there so if I can cute
you can subscribe to it on Spotify or
iTunes right now make sure to support
also make sure to follow at toast news
network we secured the handle by the way
um toast news network that's where all
of our updates for future shows are
gonna be all info on episodes that you
should definitely be listening to like
the Joey King episode check out mood
with Lauren Elizabeth tickets are
available to girls in the job stand up
on the dirty jeans tour at girl with no
job comm Kansas City Englewood New
Jersey Atlantic City New Jersey
ramaa Ontario I'm gonna be in Toronto
this weekend but it's sold out
Pittsburgh and Philly next week but
they're sold out there's a couple shows
with tickets left head over to girl with
no job comm for details and ticketing
admission and information and if this
episode is editing and you're sad about
it head over to patreon.com/scishow
morning toast for more premium content
podcasts videos this seems like you've
never [ __ ] seen us before truly we
can't thank you guys enough for
listening to the morning toasted so this
not sure is back on Tuesday I'm counting
out the campers are counting down the
days till the counselor podcast are we
good
there was one oh my birthday's on
Wednesday so I just think that's an
exciting thing that we can all be count
on super soon it's exciting because I'll
get gifts and I'm I'm gonna buy myself a
gift I'm really excited about that
that's good they don't know what it's
gonna be yet um but you know I guess
it's also depressing because I'm getting
older and that's sad well that actually
reminds me but we're all getting older
for some housekeeping announcements so
very sadly I do have to leave the
country on your birthday right her
priorities are out of whack I'm going to
a wedding in Morocco which I'm like
actually super excited for I'm so I'm
not gonna be here Wednesday for the show
Thursday Friday is Snitch
Thursday is Snitch Thursday night I am
working oh yes on I'm trying and it
seems like it's gonna happen but her
schedule is just a little we just got to
nail it down but hopefully I'll be
recording an episode with Tonya rad wow
that's gonna be really good actually
left foot most that'll be Thursday
Friday Monday I'm still not back so
probably snapped Oregon's snitch on
snatch but um thought and then very
exciting the week after that we are here
Tuesday Tuesday we jet off to the show
yet not the week after that Monday
you're not here summit on the snap week
after next week but you already on that
week okay whatever to talk about to say
I get back Monday night from Morocco
Tuesday morning we are recording an
amazing episode of the morning toast as
per usual and then we are getting on a
plane stepping into a new land jetting
off to Nashville because
Wednesday we'll do a podcast episode
Wednesday yeah just regular audio and
then Wednesday at 4 o'clock your
homegirls will be on the cma red carpet
serving up justice for everyone and just
being that is Queens that we are ya know
but on the see my red carpet were less
Queens we're more so like a new what
nuisances like we are so like
rambunctious
yeah but we're the hosts that you want
to see if you wanna see a man wear
carpet asking the questions you want
answered I'm the best time like country
music's biggest fans on country music's
biggest night there's no other mate
there's some enough that's our slogan
are we still gonna do the thing where we
make everyone like say a toast to
something no why I think that's a great
way to end the interview like you never
know know how to end it could be kind of
awkward like bye get out of our station
okay but we need to like just like get
it to be a little punchier like yeah
maybe me this is the morning toast oh
yeah I guess this is money to us what do
you wanna toast to tonight yeah and
there's everyone always has good answer
yeah like the military oh yeah winning
or like just country music you know
winning in country yeah that's actually
okay we'll bring it back thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the Millennial morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube feel free
to subscribe to us on youtube
youtube.com slash the morning shows give
this video a thumbs up leave a comment
about how stunning we are and how you
don't think we're irrelevant uglies
we are already only dude just make sure
to comment in and also subscribe create
that engagement girlfriend we're also
available as a podcast pretty much
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
iTunes Spotify stitcher Public Radio
cashbox I Heart Radio all the apps so
make sure you are subscribed to the
morning toast over there leave a five
star review about how stunning smart and
beautiful you think we are and relevant
we love you guys so much have a good
weekend don't drink and drive be safe
happy Halloween tis the season now it's
us is the season to be jolly
Lala la la la
you